foreign
just curious to know
what your best practices are for firing
well in addition to what you just
mentioned and maybe addressing the
instance of problem employees we're not
just underperforming but do something
that
catalyzes the firing
so let's take the ones that are just
firing well generally and you basically
heard it it's recognizing that when
someone gets let go it's a major life
trauma there are sort of three pillars
in your life there's your home where you
live there's your most significant
relationship you're and then there's
your your job and if any one of those
collapses at any one time it's a major
trauma if two collapse or even God
forbid three it's like oh you know
mental game over and you sort of reboot
and so recognizing that when someone's
experiencing trauma their brain just
does not work well so it's very
difficult for them to do a job search
and advocate for themselves I mean
there's a corollary you just lost your
significant relationship now you're
thinking about the effort it's not a job
search it's a partner search and the
pain that ugh how it feels overwhelming
so you're just not even starting whereas
the same thing people happens in a job
search and of course what your friends
can do to be helpful to you is help you
begin help you create the setting for
that so you don't have to do it
completely on your own that's the
corollary here the manager can help take
the first few steps for the person so
they don't have to take those steps
entirely on their own that's it that's
all we're talking about here that's
firing well and the reason it's
important to do because obviously you
think well this person isn't capable and
and why should I be helping them and
spending time with them shouldn't I be
spending time with the people who stay
here who want to be here who are
performing and the answer is is that the
people who stay are watching and they're
watching how you treat this person
because everybody at the company thinks
at some point I might be let go and if
that happens what will happen to me and
if they see that you treat this person
who got let go well and really help them
then all of a sudden a collective sigh
of relief goes through your company it's
silent you won't hear it but it'll it'll
eliminate fear and when people eliminate
fear then their brains work better and
they'll perform better
for you so you can actually look at this
as a very self-interested action I think
it is
you don't need to be selfless to help
people when you let them go you can be
very selfish and actually do this now
the second part of your question was
well what about criminal Behavior
Tim I like your edge cases yep of the
hundreds of companies I've coached and
the tens of thousands of employees maybe
even hundreds of thousands of employees
within those companies
no one has ever brought to me that I
need to let this person go for criminal
Behavior now I need to let this person
go for
what I've considered to be extreme
incompetence I can't imagine they're
good at anything
and in there I urge the CEO to get
curious yeah and just to be clear I
wasn't saying exclusively criminal
Behavior but if someone is so bad or I
mean that would be a case or someone you
look at their accounts payable and
you're like wow we are 60 days behind in
paying our vendors this should never
happen and this can't happen therefore
this person needs to be let go
because maybe conversations have been
had Etc so it's not just criminal
Behavior I will push back a little bit
and say there there is Criminal Behavior
I mean I know a lot of CEOs like there's
there's bad behavior
but I'm not limiting my hypothetical to
that yeah and maybe the CEO is a coach
have just not brought that behavior to
me because I don't want me to cause them
to fire that person well yeah or that
might be a question for the general
counsel right right exactly exactly
but when there is a situation because
this definitely does happen where people
say this person is so horrible
so egregiously irresponsible I can't
reckon them to anyone for anything well
clearly and then I would encourage that
c or that manager to just wait till time
passes wait till the anger dissipates
until
they can get curious
go to that person and find out say
clearly the facts are this you are not
qualified to do this role or clearly you
don't seem to be passionate about this
role
but what are you passionate about what
do you really enjoy and they'll say
something and then say well
let's see if that can be translated into
some kind of money making effort
and almost always it can
and what I find is that many many many
people and this is another issue with an
energy audit we can get into are
actually stuck in roles that they don't
like
some they're good at so and they get
paid well for it so they continue to do
it but over time if you don't like
something that you're doing in the end
you won't do it well you can't because
you're competing against the person
there are people out there who do like
it and they will study it and learn more
and give energy towards it and even if
they're less experienced over time they
will surpass you and far surpass you so
I find that generally humans are not
incompetent what they are is they're
uninterested
but if you can find a place where
they're interested suddenly they become
very competent
and if you can't find that place and you
need to let them go
what does that conversation look like
since you're not going to want to go on
Twitter and so on in that case if they
don't want to play ball and if they
won't share with you what their passions
are what they might be interested in or
where they might want to do that you
agree with they'd be good at then you
can't help it's like if I'm trying to
coach someone and they don't want to be
coached
it's nothing I can do yeah but you've
tried that's all you've made the offer